hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm and today we're round
number five of the twenty20 a candidates
tournament winner of this tournament
does go on to face Magnus Carlsen at the
end of the year for the World
Championship and today we have two
players tied at the top of the
tournament why it's gonna be played by
Yann diploma XI this is the player who I
called is the dark horse to win at the
tournament the favorite I think - oh the
player I'm cheering for that would be
Fabi I'm a car I wanna but his opponent
and that is how when he is not near the
top from a rating standpoint but
happening a phenomenal tournament and is
tied with yan at the top as far as
points and this is a very very important
game for both players as they get into
round number six right before the second
break they play three days in a row and
then take a day off so yan starts out
with E for and then after a 5 and 9 f3
Knight f6 getting into the Petrov
defense Knight takes here on e5 d6 these
are all the main lines after E 4 then we
see d4 d5 here solidifying this outpost
for the night here on e4 and then Bishop
to d3 in all the main lines in the
petrel defense have a video on the
Petrov offense and some lines if you're
not familiar with this opening
definitely some interesting lines you
can go down but the main line pretty
straightforward as far as how both sides
continue putting a lot of pressure on
this efore square is very vital for both
sides to control that we see castle on
the kingside Bishop to e7 preparing the
castle on the King side for black as
well
rook to e1 now we have the bishop in the
rook here attacking the square and the
bishop and the pawn defending that in
the center of the board Kass on the
Kings side and the knight to d2
attacking this knight Knight comes back
here to d6 does not like the option of
coming down and taking here on d2 and I
would agree that it's probably not the
best setup if you look at on the board
Bishop takes here on f5 now the Knights
gonna come back here to c4 not nearly as
good as if it's here on e4 it's still in
out
here but just not doing too much white
could even come up in exchange that the
Knights on board but if you look at this
why just has a much more active position
has a very very aggressive square here
on e5 it's already defended by the rook
back here has a very active light square
bishop definitely a pretty good setup
for white you can see why black may not
be looking to go and exchange that
material right away so brings the knight
back here to d6
now since that Knights not really needed
here on d2 and it is also blocking the
dark square bishop decides to come back
here to f1 later on if it wants to come
to e3 or g3 does have that option now we
see black decide to go ahead and take
the bishop here on d3 we see the
exchange definitely don't want to
recapture and have double pawns here on
the D file for no reason so it takes
with the Queen here pawn to c6 let find
this pawn chain also means that you're
probably going to see the Knights coming
here to either d7 or could also come to
a6 and then could either swing down here
to b4 or could also come to a6 swing
back here to c7 and then see what
options they have from their Bishop to
f4 just developing that dark square
Bishop also putting up for this other
rook to get involved into the action
here putting some pressure on these dark
squares in the center of the board
Knight to a6 is the option that's how
wing decides to go with and then h4 over
here White has a very active position
here decides to start pushing on the
King side of the board Knight to c7
Knight up here to a g5 so it's got the
little outpost here Bishop and queen are
both attacking the square but the bishop
in the pawn here are defending that
nicely Bishop takes and the bishop
recaptures here want to make sure that
you take back with the right material it
would definitely be a mistake to take
with the pawn right here mostly because
Knight to e6 is pretty difficult to deal
with attacking both the bishop and the
pawn right here
if
you know the bishop can't do too much
here it could just retreat which you
don't want to have your Bishop move back
you want to have this pretty aggressive
here and you have both the knight in the
Queen attacking this so it's gonna be
very difficult to hold on to this
material so could decide in this case to
go ahead and take this material but then
after the Queen takes here the Knights
still attacking this you're really going
to have to either push pawns forward
more than you would like to get your
Queen into a position you may not like
it as well
all in all definitely not the position
that white wants much better position to
go ahead and take with the bishop now
the Knights still over here on c7 it's
not as active the Queen's not gonna be
moving anytime soon so white definitely
has the upper hand compared to if he
decided to take with his pawn here on g5
now pawn f6 threatening the bishop the
bishops forced to move once it does do
this this does weaken the King side a
little bit it's a little bit better
knowing that there's not the
LightSquared Bishop can attack obviously
the Queen is on the board so the Queen
can at some points get to these light
squares eventually Black's gonna want to
bring his King over here to h8 just get
a little bit more protection here on the
King side Queen to d7 it is being
blocked by the pawn here on f6 so trying
to find ways to get the Queen involved
into the game also opening up the door
for this other rook to get involved as
well
chess is all about getting your pieces
involved into the game trying to
maximize the amount of squares that they
can really go to on the board Queens
obviously want to have the most cores
they can get to at all times and you
want to connect your rooks on at the
backline so that's why you're seeing
some of these moves for those newer
players checking out the candidates
tournament I try to explain some of the
the opening moves the development moves
that you'll see from both sides Knight
to g3 about time that we get this knight
involved in the game wasn't doing too
much here on the f1 Square rook to e8
and then we see the bishop take here on
d6 we do see the exchange
now that up here to f5 part of the
reason that the bishop decided to take
here on d6 is you gain this one little
tempo meaning your knight comes up here
- f5 and you essentially force the Queen
to move King comes back here to d7 Queen
over here to h3 you do have a nice
defense on this Knights and also
threatening something like Knight to h6
obviously black is not gonna fall for
this you may see something a a weaker
player maybe club level or below fall
for something like this this would be a
discovered attack on the Queen
check with your Knights right here and
then the Queen would fall but we see
King to h8 blacks definitely not going
to fall for that and then Y decides to
start pushing forward on the Kings side
the board here with h5 rook takes on e 1
we do see in exchange right here rook to
e8 and then these come off the board so
both sides equal in material getting
into the endgame not clear how either
side is going to win but if anything
white definitely has a more aggressive
setup here his Knights in the center of
the board
it's already on f5 right here the knight
back here for black is on the e8 square
so it's gonna take some time to get
involved into the game as far as the
Queen's whites a little bit more active
the Kings are both pretty safe right
here but but truly I don't see a path
very clearly for either side to go ahead
and win from here young continues with
g4 says if there's anything I'm gonna
try to find it starts pushing on the
Kings side of the board with the Kings
side pretty much spoken for with the
knight the Queen and all these ponds we
see how a wing decides to start pushing
on the Queen side of the board
b3 from whites Queen to e6 just
centralizing that Queen a little bit
more then back here to e3 just stopping
the Queen threat from coming down here
to e1 starting to check the opponent
maybe get get behind enemy lines start
to attack these pawns over here on the
Queen side of the board Knight to d6
definitely want to get that Knight
involved into the game h6 here we do see
g6 just stopping that threats on the
King side of the board c4 we do see the
exchange right here King to g8 Queen
down here to h2 just says yeah if you
want to take material I'm gonna swing
my queen up here and start to attack we
see the king to f7 now pawn to c5 this
says yeah you can't take my pawn right
here because I can't swing up here and
check your King and take some material
here so has a nice solid pawn chain
decides to bring his knight over here to
b5 now Queen to be a de and this is a
tricky spot finding where black should
go to in this position is not easy
I think if most people analyze this
position for a while they would figure
out just how tricky this is from black
if we look at some of the options here
one would be the Queen takes here on a 2
now this would be the worst option but
it may just on the surface look like a
decent option to go ahead and start
taking material here you threaten your
opponents now you have your Queen back
you can always start checking your
opponents but that's what--when to lose
Queen takes on and b7 check then you're
gonna have depending on where that the
King goes to you have Queens to c6
taking material check King over here to
d8 Queen takes on f6 just gobbling up
material here and checking at the same
time here Queen takes on h7 all of a
sudden you see all this material coming
off the board here two others now a
passed pawn on the H file which is gonna
be very dangerous for black to have to
deal with you have these two pawns in
the center how does black really
continue I could try to check your
opponent that's fine but then it doesn't
take too long for black to run out of
moves to continue to attack so maybe
Knight takes on d4 trying to get some of
that material back Queen up to h8 and
it's very difficult for black to win
from here if we come back instead Knight
comes down here to b5 Queen to d8 and
then maybe now we see the knight take
here on d4 gobbling up someone's hero
here it's not protected but then Queens
takes on b7 gets that pawn back in
material maybe Queen to e7 Queens takes
here on a6 so why does up material gives
back that material right here so both
sides have a passed pawn but then we
could see queen up here to c8 may be
Queenie 7 comes back
swings to h8 and starts to attack it's
very difficult to hold on to all this
material here with the King here on f7
it's almost blocking the material that
black has to defend this h7 square and
as soon as this H Evans Square falls
this pawn here on h6 it's going to have
a pretty easy path to start marching up
the board here Knight to f3 King f1
Knight comes back here to g5 holding on
to this material probably the best way I
can find that black would still hold on
to this material here on h7 Queen over
here c8 potentially Queen b6 maybe Queen
to b7
check this is just one variation that we
could come down here and then Y could
start marching on the Queen side of the
board with the pond so those are all
options that you could see the best
option that the computers came up with
as they were analyzing this game was
Queen to e7 so Queen up here to be 8 and
then Queen to e7 now it may look very
subtle as far as the difference between
what the computer said is the optimal
move and that is Queen to e7 and the
move that was actually played that when
black went with Queen to d7 well first
look at the Queen to e7 after Queen h8
attack in this pond we see King to e6
this is really the best way for black to
hold on to this critical square here on
h7 remember soon as this pawn falls very
easy for the pawns have push up here and
promote on the h8 Square from here we
could see f4 now this will see this
position here in a minute and how it's
very different but if the pawn comes up
here to f4 now the knight comes down
takes on d4 if the pawn pushes forward
to f5 you can see this is not gonna work
pawn takes here Knight takes Knight
recaptures on f5 pawn takes and then the
King takes and there's no real way for
white to continue in this spot black
should easily be able to even overrun
white in this position has way more
pawns very difficult to attack the King
here can start to bring his Queen down
and start to attack as much as you wants
to now let's go back
take a look at the position when instead
of king two or Queen to e7 we see Queen
to d7 very subtle but now the Queen's
gonna come over here to h8 King to e6
same thing now f4 so all these moves are
the same and this is what happened in
the game Knight takes on d4 the main
difference is Queen to g8 one this is
first check now the Queen comes over
here to f7 now Queen to c8 check and
this is forcing the Queen to come over
here to d7 not necessarily the best move
the optimal move actually instead of
coming to c8 was Queen to d8 but lucky
for whites we just see the Queen come to
d7 Queen comes back here and we repeat
the same thing and then y'all learn from
his mistakes and then plate Queen to d8
now why is this so different is because
now the queen is on d7 whereas before it
was on e7 and this is vitally important
because now when the pawn comes to f5
the pawn takes here now the pawn can
take and after the Knight takes then the
Queen can take now once the King takes
up here on d7 the knight takes here on
f5 so these one small differences in the
moves from east 7 and d7 have very
drastic changes in the position that
ended up with all the commentators are
looking at thinking this is a drawn game
there's no way for white to really break
through here unless black makes a
mistake he ended up playing Queen to d7
and at the end of that white ended up
with a victory played a few more moves
here tonight back here to e3 and black
decided to resign realize that he
calculated incorrectly this night would
be able to overwhelm start to gobble up
all the this material here and he would
eventually lose so white takes the
victory Yan gets the win and moves to
top place in the tournament he
was the only victory today so everyone
else got the drawl and he was able to
now take the sole position in first
place going into round number six so
congratulations to him it's always nice
when you play someone else tied at the
top and you get the full point from them
hopefully you guys are enjoying the
tournament and the coverage we will be
back tomorrow for round number six but
thank you guys so much for watching the
coverage